all right Katarina hi Katarina where'd
you grow up where you from originally um
I grew up in Bridgeport Connecticut um
born and
raised
um I was uh born in Bridgeport Hospital
um but both of my parents um I'm
Ecuadorian and Cuban actually so um
grandparents came here as immigrants um
so my entire family like I'm only second
generation so yeah um now I live in
Shelton and yeah how would you describe
your
childhood um childhood
was
H it was tough um I mean I I received
everything that I needed um you know I
you know I always had food on the table
you know a roof over my head so not much
to complain about but um I started uh
receiving you know just weird symptoms
here and there and that exacerbated in
my life and I think that that made my
childhood tough but there was no abuse
from the parents or anything like that
no no
um parents didn't really handle mental
illness well but not like you know not
like punching or you know not nothing
like that were you diagnosed at some
point with yes so I am diagnosed with
did um dissociative identity disorder um
and I also am diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder um Can can you
describe what did is of course so did um
a lot of people think that it's a
personality disorder um but it's
actually technically a dissociative
disorder so how did works is um
basically every single person in the
world including yourself includ you know
anybody we all have internal systems so
it's like how you are right now is going
to be different than how you are you
know with your family or with your kids
or stuff like that the only difference
with did is that it's a lot more
fragmented
um so for example yeah so for example
like I as um a system which is what call
people with did I unfortunately even
through endless therapy endless work
endless psychedelics which we'll get to
um I do not remember my core trauma um a
lot of people with did don't remember
their core trauma that started it that
started me splitting basically um
believe it has to do with sexual abuse
um but don't remember the first trauma
um however uh how I knew that I started
splitting how I started noticing
something was off was that when I was
only about 5 to six years old I started
hurting myself I started basically like
sexually abusing myself and I remember I
started losing time so like I
would get you know severe nightmares or
like I would um start feeling literally
like I was a different
person but I wasn't aware to what
exactly that was like I didn't
understand it especially as a child you
know you don't get it you're still
forming so because of that it makes did
extremely tough to diagnose it actually
almost take me it almost took me 20
years to be diagnosed with did properly
and
um yeah so I uh I had been in therapy
starting only from when I was 11 and
I had actually seen over uh 23
therapists really yeah and it wasn't
until my 24th one that truly just she
really took care of me like no other
therapist had and she was the one that
properly diagnosed me with both did and
BPD
co-occurring um weirdly it seems like my
did is getting better as I get older but
it seems like my BPD is getting worse um
but it's it's an ongoing J Journey every
day by far you mentioned that you were
sexually abusing yourself yes so you you
don't think there was some any some some
form of sexual trauma in your childhood
I 100% believe that there probably was
um you you don't remember it I don't
remember the core memory um there is a
possible person maybe that some of my
family members believe could have done
something but we're not 100% sure um is
that what you're 24 therapist thinks
yeah yeah um we actually did um EMDR um
I don't remember what it stands for I
think it's eye
movement desens something like that um
and yes and we had to go really deep in
therapy is that
helpful it's really tough
um it's I've heard completely
conflicting views for EMD are for did
some people think that it can help
memories come up that we don't know what
caused certain traumas and then other
people think that it's way too brutal um
for me when I did EMDR I've only done it
a few times with my therapist and it
slowly started to integrate me but at
the same time it's just so much on my
body that it's like I stopped doing
it um yeah hard for you to to process or
even look at what happened hard to
process I mean I I deal with it I'm
really strong when it comes to that
stuff you know I I know the the process
of it I um I think what I mean by
difficult as in aside from the did for
me a lot of it is sematic so like what I
mean by that is like like even just what
I have right now like just talking about
it is making me shake and
like you know it makes me forgetful so
that makes it very very hard to hold
down a job so like a lot of the time
when I've been in school or I have been
working I will sometimes literally skip
time so like for example um I didn't
finish High School um I did now I I
finally got my GED later on but um for
example I didn't finish high school
because there was one day where I had
some blowout that people told me about
and I literally left school like I left
the premises and um I just walked to
some nun
Monastery uh randomly a couple miles
down and I don't remember that chunk of
time so going through therapy like yes
it's helpful but it can also trigger
that it could trigger that to get worse
at first and that's really really tough
especially in today's world so so with
did your behavior will be such that you
will just do things
without like awareness of it or it's
almost like a different person different
part of your personality doing it yes
it's literally it literally feels like a
different person it um that's that's how
I knew that there was something up very
young I didn't know what I didn't even
know what did was until I was diagnosed
with it when she told me I was like what
the [__] is that I I had no idea um like
I had heard maybe like you know multiple
personality in movies but it's like it's
nothing I ever researched it's not
really talked about um so but the reason
that I knew that there was something
that was wrong was because my entire
childhood especially 11 to 20 years old
it was to the severity that different
parts of me have different genders
different sexualities different beliefs
different
interests and it was cycling through
those different parts that are so hard
especially not having been diagnosed for
so long because then it's like who am I
like who it like I don't understand and
I started getting to like maybe other
people deal with this and it wasn't
until I was diagnosed that I realized
like no this is a severe thing that I'm
dealing with they're they're all me
they're just different forms of me
they're all different parts of a person
that tried to protect me from some
something that I don't
remember yeah and how and how does
borderline personality disorder coexist
with the
did so
borderline is basically a severe fear of
Abandonment
and there is also switching in
borderline but it's not switching in the
sense of different personalities it's
switching in the sense of going emotion
to emotion so how that feels for me is
like
um for example
like I can feel safe with my partner and
then all of a sudden they could just say
something that's like mild like you know
even just you know I have to go to work
tomorrow and then all of a sudden my
head takes it from 1 to 100 and it goes
as far as like I I you know I don't want
to be with you like I'm questioning
everything um and it took me years to
realize that I have to that I feel that
as is but it's like I have to keep it
from an outside perspective and I used
to act on it and it took a lot of years
to be able
to deal with it from an outside
perspective and accept it but not act on
it and that took a lot of different
relationships going through and burning
to the
ground um so how how old are you now I'm
I just turned 28 28 you you've had
boyfriends boyfriends and girlfriends
girlfriends yes a lot of different
partners um my partner that I currently
have now we've known each other actually
since uh we were both
11 and they've always been in my life
but
my mental illness got very much in the
way to having a proper stable
relationship with them and um it wasn't
until only the last like 5 years or so
that we've had a healthy relationship
and I mean it's still very hard because
I still deal with you know I still deal
with this but it's like I'm able to just
have an awareness so like I know if
those feelings come up yes it's
something that's triggering me but it
doesn't mean I have to act on it it
doesn't mean I have to be destructive
and sometimes I am but it's a lot better
than it used to
be do you do you feel like this was
caused by something that happened to you
when you were young or do you
think are there other people in your
family that have similar problems um
that I know of no um
I mean I feel like the most sane one in
my family um
but that I know of I I don't know if
there's any mental illness aside from me
um I'm assuming so um there is and has
been a lot of abuse I know that um
there's been sexual abuse as well in
family and I'm a huge believer that that
carries
generationally
um
I I was always a very deep and sensitive
child and um I was always very
existential so um I remember just always
being the type of kid
that sorry I'm
just
I remember
just being a very existential child and
being
um very
serious
[Music]
and I really believe that my symptoms
started extremely young I mean it's
obvious that it
did
and people surrounding me didn't know
how to deal with that and I know that
that made it a 100 times harder on
me
um my father in
particular who I have a lot of trauma
with
um did not know how to react to me um
neither my parents did so because of
that my childhood was just filled with a
lot of hospitalizations and um therapy
and just fighting and there was even a
time when I ran away and
um I I I know
that a lot of that had to do with just
not being properly diagnosed not being
properly taken care of in that
sense um and I mean I I don't blame my
parents
but I feel like a lot of my traumas had
to do with me putting myself in
dangerous
situations because I was acting out from
a pace of a place of mental pain that I
didn't know any better that no one knew
any better and it wasn't until I was
diagnosed that I told a couple of loved
ones and they were like oh that makes
sense you know that you know now I
understand why you used to act out that
way not why you used to change or um
there was even um when I told my stepmom
she was uh relieved but she was also
upset because she told me a bunch of
memories that I don't remember such as
like her being in the kitchen with me
and then me just being like happy and
bubbly and then her saying one thing and
then her just literally seeing me shut
down and just losing time for like five
minutes are your personalities different
yes severely like different people
yes and are you aware of it are you
looking at yourself going oh now I'm
being this
person at first no um not at all I
didn't have any Consciousness to it um
through a a shitload of therapy I do
mostly have a Consciousness to it now I
think it's called co-consciousness in
the did community so now when I'm
switching um I do totally have an
awareness but it's not I still can't
really control it I have to just let it
be how different are they from the
personality I'm talking to right
now right now I can't tell today I've
already switched like three times um it
was happening in the
car um I start like twitching and
blinking um or sometimes I'll just zone
out that's my most common it feels kind
of like falling
asleep um and then sometimes times
nothing happens at all like I'll just
feel it and then you know um a lot of
the time for me it's triggered by
something
negative um but sometimes it doesn't
have to be sometimes I could just
be watching you know a childhood show
that I saw that came on when I was
little and it'll
happen um but all of these parts are
just reflections of something that was
trying to protect me from different
things in my
life
and you were how old when you learned
that this was your
diagnosis um 20
23 23 or 24 must have been confusing for
you up until then it was really
confusing it
was I felt Bittersweet towards it I was
actually thinking about that on the way
here like how I felt and it was
bittersweet because part of me was like
that 100% % makes sense 100% And when I
researched it I was like holy [__] but
then there was another part that was
like holy [__] like upsetting like okay
that's you know this is going to be a
lifelong
journey do do you have hope of it
getting better or changing oh yeah I
totally have hope um I kind of know that
this will always be a part of me
especially the BPD for some reason I
just know but um I do definitely have
have hope hope of it getting better I
see it get better
um uh my hope I don't even know if I
want to fully integrate um but I
do hope that I can at least just maybe
be able to function
easier um by
far um I am actually in the myths right
now of micro doing um I don't know if
you know what that is micro doing with
mushrooms yeah yeah so that's been an
interesting
Journey um
yeah the borderline personality disorder
how serious does that get for
you I've heard some horrifying
stories it's a lot better
now um than when I was younger when I
was in my teens it was just it was just
really brutal it
was just doing the most outlandish
things and
unfortunately um my relationships the
ones in the past I can admit that the
reason that they ended was because I was
pretty abusive sadly which I take full
responsibility for now um I would just
act out in these one to 100 ways and I I
still feel that the only difference is
that I I try to cope with it I try
to
I try to
um not ignore it but accept it as is
sometimes I have to ignore
it like
um just the other day
um I forgot that there there was
something that happened where I I
couldn't get in contact with both my mom
and my
partner and I just started thinking like
they hate me and you know and I started
crying and I started thinking of like
hurting myself myself and it just goes
one to 100 really quick and that part I
still deal
with um but the more severe cases of you
know like running away and you know
starting
like trying to act out ways to off
myself just being blunt um those I like
to think I've definitely healed from
that I've definitely
come back from because I know that how
I'm feeling in those moments it is going
to pass I'm just I'm feeling it in that
moment are you working
currently no um I have a lot of trouble
holding down a job
um the easiest thing that I'm able to do
every once in a while is um uh gig work
so like you know Uber uh roie
um you know door Dash I'm sorry I don't
do Uber anymore I don't know why I said
that um just you know basic shitty jobs
like that um but sometimes I go weeks
without doing it because I just can't or
I've dissociating more or sometimes I
will dissociate while driving and that's
not good or
I just overall do not feel
okay
um
unfortunately because of you know the
trauma and the the mental
illness I as well also deal with uh
physical stuff as well so um I
have um a thyroid condition and um I
have a really shitty
fibromyalgia and um I am a whole
believer in the entire mindbody
connection very much so I see it um and
because of that that makes it hard to
hold down a job um at the moment I'm
actually in the myths of trying to apply
for at least
SSI um disability is very hard for me to
get on because my uh disability started
when I was very young um I have medical
records going back past 11 years old and
I've never worked so I don't
have experience and they want you to at
least have worked a little bit so I'm
trying to get SSI right now at least and
just to have
that that backup um but I still I still
do desire to work you know I'm trying
every day to think of something to think
of what I can do I'm even considering
going to school just to at least you
know try to do
something what would you say is your
greatest fear
now um it's silly but Financial I feel
bad um you know my mom knows what I deal
with we don't talk about it um I'm not
in a family that talks about
anything yeah
um uh you know I'm Spanish so it's like
Infamous for not talking about important
stuff
um but my mom knows that I struggle um
she gives me support and that means
everything to me um but my biggest fear
is what I'm going to do after because I
know she's not going to be around
forever and I don't like counting on
people and um I have some ideas I mean
even if I have to live in a motor home
but that's a fear that I have right now
um aside from
that um you know I try to keep strong
you know I've kind of been through the
worst already so I have faith in myself
more than I used
to and Karina what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
all of
this
H that I can count on
myself that I have to that um I know
that even when the [__] hits the fan
that I have
myself um and others sorry that was a
bad
joke um that I you know that I've been
through it I've been through a lot and I
have a lot to
share and
that I don't know I just have that
resilience within me that I've seen pull
me through you know the darkest pits of
the earth and having that calms me at
the end of the
day all right Karina thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you I wish
you lots of luck with everything you're
going through thank you very much thank
you thank
you